hello YouTube chest lowers this is good
gin here and this is my first ever video
on YouTube and I like to say thank you
for watching this video I try to make
this video as much interesting as I
could and today I'm going to show you
our trap and kairkhan defense this game
was played by me on Yahoo at the time my
rating was 1600 and my opponent was like
around 1800 and he was really strong
like he just beat me before this game
are 2 to 2 games and he beat me quite
easily and because he has a really
strong middle game and I'm learning
right now so I was not that much good
but anyways this game was something
different it was really good come out
from me let's start with E E - E 4 and
then my opponent played a kayak on
defense which is C 6 and then I opened
up with the d 4 D 5 D 4 and then he
played D Phi which is a usual line for a
carry Conda fence the line continued
with I played Knight f3 and he just took
that epon and I took back with my night
and then he bring out his night at f6
generally at this clays sometimes the
black black player play first Knight to
d7 and then Knight web 6 but my opponent
doesn't like he doesn't go for that he
decided to bring his knight on f3 and I
decided to like defend my knight with
the Queen and also being my queen out
and somewhat a middle center and at this
point my opponent play a really strange
move which is just kind of shock to me
because generally you you don't see
often this kind of moves on Carrick on
defense but he played here
'if i which is a kind of unusual because
in katakana defiance generally you don't
see players play like open the lines
like that generally they just develop a
small Center near the sixth like the six
lines and then the defense like castle
the King on the Kings side and attack on
the Queen side but that's not the case
here he just tried to open up it lines
view and for a moment I just think on
this I think that if I take this pawn it
will be not at all bad for me because
you know after taking this pawn even if
the Queen's exchange I can take with my
bishop and now this e pawn is hard to
defend for the black and white will be a
piece up here for instant like if you
take the Knights take night and I take
by the bishop and now the this part is
really easy to define for me by the F
pawns it's it's great supported by a
pawns
so here the white will be upon hope and
it will be a good game for the wife so I
was thinking that he will not go for the
lines so I decide what like what other
things he can do and I can see here that
he can probably check me and I can move
my bishop over here and then he can take
this pawn by his Queen but in this case
I can castle on the Queen side and then
my rook can come on the e-file and
attack on his King and because you know
his king and queen is in a line so it
will be hard for the black to just
generally quickly go on King side castle
and probably I have a good chance of
attacking on his King so in this case
even if the black takes this Knight
it's just a taking of piece for a while
because you know the rook can come on
the F file and if if we try to support
the night I can just kick this night out
and like he can't move this night
because if skiing and communion a line
so he has to move his Queen somewhere
and then I can take back this night so I
think all of this and I think there's
nothing wrong to take that pawn so I
decided to take it and my opponent play
exactly what I think he checked me with
the Queen and I play my Bishop over here
and he just stick that pawn with the
Queen and I cancelled and at this
position uh I think that my opponent
make a big blunder by taking this night
and if you can pause the video here and
let's see can you find the really good I
think I have to say a winning line for
the wide desk let's take a try okay
welcome back to move here it's it's
quite unusual but lots of people I don't
know probably you finding it not but the
real good a really good move is Queen to
d8 and it's it's really hard hard for my
opponent because you know when - was
playing this game
my opponent look for like probably 30 or
40 seconds to look at the look at the
step and here black doesn't matter it
doesn't have any choice he has to dis
this Queen because there's no other
options left for the black and the King
take the screen and now I count with her
discover check a double chat with my
king and Bishop sorry my rook and Bishop
so his King has to move but which is the
nice place here and ideally officially
there's only two legal moves available
here for the black scheme one is either
two King goes to the e8 but in that case
my rook can come over here and the back
is checkmate
so my opponent doesn't go for that and
he decide the other option which is to
move the King on c7 but again in this
case my bishop can come over here and
that's the checkmate
so it's it was a nice revenge for me I
just win like really easily in this game
and I think this game was really nice so
I I thought that I should share with the
YouTube Chancellor's thank you for
watching my video I see you next time
bye